i found this quote from you that i
really loved you said reading an hour a
day is only four percent of your day but
that four percent will put you at the
top of your field within 10 years and it
actually reminded me of something that
stephen cutler taught me which is that
books are the best roi on your time so
i'd love to understand how reading
changed your life i mean you said it
earlier right 1.8 gpa first time i
finished the book cover to cover i was
21 years old and then once i read a
business book i'm like i can't believe
this isn't a book i've written now over
2 000 books and god knows how many
business articles
and that led me to who i am today i
think it's an edge be careful what you
joke about or be sarcastic about because
your spirit stops having faith and wars
that come out of your mouth boom that's
power highest form of maturity becomes
is when you become independent of others
opinions oh that's awesome so all of
these things were being added one by one
by one by one by one again by product of
books and then eventually they stick and
you you start becoming these quotes